Speaking of responsibility, it's always only
a matter of time until the Jews are blamed
for anything on this planet.
And I've been waiting for it to happen with
the virus, and it now has.
And in fact, this started back in January.
It just only has been taking hold now.
Small groups of white nationalists back in
January started propagating the idea that
a shadowy cabal of Jews created the virus.
Now, why would Jews create the virus?
Well, of course, it's so that then Jews can
profit from later curing the virus.
This is not just being said by white supremacists.
On obscure blogs, Turkish national television
hosted a guest who argued that Jews, Zionists
and others Jews and Zionists, I guess, have
organized and engineered the virus as a biological
weapon like bird flu to design the world sees
countries for themselves and neuter the world's
population.
So there's kind of like there's two or three
different hypotheses about why Jews created
the virus.
You've got the people who say Jews created
the virus to then profit from curing it.
The other anti-Semitic virus theory is that
Jews created the virus in order to take down
Trump.
I guess, you know, correctly identifying that
most Jews are liberals.
The idea being you create the virus to make
Trump look bad.
Now, unfortunately, way more people are dying
in other countries.
So again, if it's all meant to take down Trump,
there's a lot of collateral damage here.
And then thirdly is the idea that Jews created
the virus in order to cull the gentile population
and to position Jews.
I mean, I can't even do it so stupid that
I can't even do it all.
But I think you guys get the idea.
Now, this isn't true.
This isn't new.
Obviously, it's not true.
It's also not new.
Back in the 14th century, we had the Black
Plague.
The Black Plague was blamed on Jews.
And in fact, many Jews were massacred.
Jewish communities were sometimes massacred
over the false claim that Jews were responsible
for the Black Plague.
Even back then.
Now, unfortunately, the fomenting of these
theories is being increased by the fact that
you have some Israeli research labs that are
making a lot of progress on a vaccine and
on treatments for the virus.
I told you last week that the Galilee Research
Institute in Israel already has a poultry
corona virus vaccine.
They've been able to modify it so that it
would work on humans.
And they are now pushing forward on trials
of that vaccine.
This is bolstering the idea that Jews created
the virus in order to the then profit from
it, because we've seen some people anecdotally
say if Israel is the one that develops the
vaccine.
I don't trust that.
I don't want it.
It's really important to understand in these
times of crisis, everyone has their own hammer.
And so everything always looks like a nail
to them.
We've seen so many of these examples in the
last 10 days.
You've got the conspiracy theorists and the
deep staters coming up with stuff like this
is a Chinese bio weapon.
This is a population control method for by
the deep state to keep the population down.
The anti-Semites predictably come up with,
well, this is the Jews.
Of course, the Trump sycophants come up with
this is a Democrat hoax to make Trump look
bad.
The Christian televangelist grifters immediately
come up with this is an.
Opportunity to offer one of our pseudo-science
quack products and claim that it cures the
virus, we had Jim Baker talking about drinkable
silver as a cure.
Alex Jones obviously always has a product.
In this case, it's a toothpaste.
He says it cures the virus.
We had televangelist Kenneth Copeland worth
three quarters of a billion dollars who decided
people should send me money and I'll pray
for them to be cured.
On and on and on.
It's predictable.
It's counterproductive.
And we're just going to have to work around
these people.
There's no other way around it.
They're not going to be part of the solution.
They're going to be an impediment to the solution.
We just have to work around them.